good morning welcome to the American
enterprises yeah buddy hey we're honored
to have someone who needs no
introduction but I'm gonna give him one
anyway Senator Lindsey Graham came to
the United States Senate in 2002 after
an eight-year career in the house in the
house where he was the first Republican
to direct it from his district since
reconstruction and in the House and
Senate he developed a reputation as a
leader of national security party policy
a fighter for a conservative
internationalism and American engagement
in the world and he is also a proud
member of the 1% the 1% of Americans who
actually serve our nation in uniform he
had a 33 career year career as an Air
Force lawyer both an active-duty and in
the garden Reserve and so he brings a
perspective to national security or the
policy maker in Washington and also
someone who's worn our nation's uniform
so we're very proud to have you here at
AEI
well thank you a word will mark a lot
and live to tell about it so that's
pretty good well so you you've often
said that that border security is
national security so we'd be remiss not
to start with immigration and I'm gonna
ask you I'm not gonna ask you to confirm
or deny anything that was said and that
in that meeting the other day but I want
to ask you about the other meeting that
took place in the White House that you
also attended that week when the
President of the United States expressed
a desire to not only legalize the
dreamers but to pursue comprehensive
immigration reform that would legalize
11 million illegal immigrants who are in
this country and he said that he would
take the heat if Senator Durbin and
members of Congress were willing to do
that that's a remarkable offer from a
president who has made cracking down on
illegal immigration of a central tenet
of his tenure do you think that it's the
comprehensive immigration reform of
something that could happen well I think
it has to eventually the Tuesday Trump I
like that guy come back wherever you
went come back so here's the deal with a
Tuesday Trump he brings in a bunch of
members of Congress House and Senate
commands the room he's funny he's
engaging and knows what he's talking
about he's a great listener he's the guy
that I like playing golf with and he
talked about several things I don't want
to repeat the mistakes of the past we
need border security including a wall
I want merit
immigration how many of you here want
merit-based immigration I do how many of
you believe we meet need more legal
immigration I do if you run a business
is started to find workers so he laid
out a pathway on the economic side of
memmer immigration it made sense to me
more legal immigration breaking chain
migration which is one green card holder
can bring in a ton of people we're gonna
try to limit it to nuclear family and
that frees up thousands of green cards
for workers that all makes sense then he
said we're going to do it with love now
the this Homeland Security Secretary
didn't hear the word love I did now
Trump doesn't say love a lot but he said
it and quite frankly I thought it was
compelling and one of the best
performances by a president since I've
been up here what happened I have no
idea what happened Thursday in terms of
what changed but I do know how this
movie ends and I want you to know how it
ends we're not going to leave 800,000
people with no place else to go out in
the cold the DREAM Act population have
one thing in common they came here at a
relatively young age the average is six
they've lived here a long time they've
gone through a criminal vetting process
they add value to the country and we're
going to fix their problem for a
Republican to believe that we will get
all the defense funding we desperately
want in need and we'll deal with the
dreamers later how naive can you be to
the Republican leadership who have craft
sequestration Ronald Reagan Reagan is
rolling over in his grave
of all the dumb ideas I've been witness
to sequestration was the top of the list
for me why mark the idea was we're going
to cut 1.2 trillion dollars out of the
budget over a decade count me in for
reducing spending we're going to spend
47 billion so 1.2 shouldn't be that hard
to find the supercommittee was gonna
lead us to the promised land but in case
they failed we're going to have a call
clause called sequestration will cut 1.2
but we'll do it across the board
half from the fence and half from
non-defense discretionary spending and
we won't touch entitlements so when I
heard that I said oh my god if this
actually became law Congress has shot
down more planes than any enemy we've
sunk more ships when you look at the
damage we've done in the military no
enemy could hope to do this so with
Congress assumed the worst and you're
seldom to go wrong so the supercommittee
didn't work calling it super doesn't
make it better so it failed
sequestration kicked in in 2011 and the
military's in a bad way and those who
created this mess need to help me fix it
so I want to say one thing in case
anybody's listening I'm in two camps I
believe we should take care of the DREAM
Act kids now not wait to March 5th and
we should increase defense spending now
so those who think that we're going to
get away as Republicans while getting
all we want on defense now and we'll
deal with the kids later the DREAM Act
population closer to March 5th when
their backs against the wall that is it
that is nuts and I am going to take this
message to the floor of the Senate and
I'm in the camp of doing something right
by the dreamers and doing something
right by the military and do it now and
do it together let's talk about phase 2
though the phase 2 was a comprehensive
reform so the president most people were
shocked by what the president said about
comprehensive reform but in fact he
can't if you watch what he said during
the campaign he campaigned on a policy
that you're familiar with called
touchback right which is the idea that
as long as these people go back to their
home countries the good ones get to come
back in an expedited fashion to work
here permanently you were one of the
original authors I've been a gang you
can be so so is that why is that a
possibility and to is this really a
unique opportunity in the sense that I'm
just like only Nixon could go to China
maybe only donald trump could sign a
comprehensive immigration reform well
mark not only this is like nixon goes to
china doesn't come back
but that's how big it would be if Donald
Trump actually could get this time and I
think you can I think he wants to but
he's got to take the heat so what does
phase two look like it looks like we're
going to secure the border firmly and
completely we're going to deal with the
visa overstays because if you don't
you've left 40 percent of illegal
immigrants behind
if you don't crease legal immigration
you're hurting the economy and one of
the reasons people hire illegals they
can't find workers and they cheat so we
need a national Avera fine the future to
make sure employers are doing it right
we need to secure our border we need to
reform the visa system we need a wall
but not just a wall
we need to crease legal immigration and
we need to iver file system why so we
don't have 11 million 20 years from now
to get that you got to deal with the 11
million the way this movie ends is that
the non bad hombres the 11 million
who've been here a long time can come
out of the shadows if they're not a
felon that committed three misdemeanors
they can stay and over a 10-year period
they can work toward a green card they
have to pass an English proficiency exam
have to pay taxes and they have to get
in the back of the line and have to have
a job they have to do all those things
in return we get a merit-based
immigration system where we bring people
in based on the economic needs of the
country from all over the world not just
Norway and we start issuing green cards
based on minor children and spouses to
go away from family based immigration to
merit-based immigration that's phase two
that's the gang of eight bill every time
you talk about this it's like you
discover a new country nothing's being
said today that hasn't been said before
Bush tried it he got 42% of the spanic
vote we're down to the mid 20s now
you'll never convince me that the way
we've handled immigration has not hurt
us with Hispanic community a community
that should be our voters so I'm hopeful
that we can get through phase one I'm
hopeful we can go under comprehensive
and the one thing about President Trump
he has credible
with the right that no one else has so
when he says the border secure I think
most people are gonna believe him I
think he's really the only guy can do
this and if we fail then shame on us all
do the Democrats really want to cut a
deal with Donald Trump to do all that I
mean the fact that that in for you know
if when the number-two leader of the
regardless and positing that what
sitters and Trump said in that meeting
if it's true was terrible if you're the
number-two leader of the Democrats in
the Senate and you're trying to
negotiate a deal with the President of
the United States and you're really
serious about it do you leak that or do
you just ignore it and push forward
and try and get a deal it strikes me
that they prefer the part of the
politics and the issue than the attend
solving it no doubt in my mind that dick
Durbin wants to deal in spite of what
said he said that yesterday sometimes
there's some things said that are going
to get out because they shouldn't have
been said the way they were said I would
imagine if it been a democratic
president saying some pretty well things
would hurt about it so leaking it is not
unknown to this town what's unknown is
inviting the number two Democrat into a
meeting and have the president stuck to
the ceiling not very not very good staff
work so there are some Democrats running
in 2020 who will never accept the
concept of the wall they don't support
our proposal because the president gets
his wall money for FY 18 there's some
Democrats who are playing for the left I
won't do anything with Donald Trump
during the resist movement most
Democrats want to deal most Republicans
have gotten to the point now where we
will deal with the 11 mean if we get
something for it
amnesty used to be you got to boil them
in oil and if you're not willing to do
that you're soft
amnesty moved to that they can stay here
but they can't be citizens now amnesty
is chain migration I like Tom cotton
he's a very good guy national security
issues but Tom Cotton's want the
Democrats for the daka population to
change family based immigration that's
what you get at the end not at the front
we're not going to give 11 million
people legal status and hope the
Democrats still with us on merit-based
immigration and border
security it doesn't work that way so
yeah there's a deal there's plenty of
Democrats who want a deal all right
let's talk about national security so
Friday is one year mark one year mark of
prison Trump's inauguration broad
question is how are we doing on the
world stage compared to where we were a
year ago today great compared to a year
ago I'm the happiest guy in town why
because we've got a president who
actually wants to rebuild the military
with the lowest spending per GDP on
defense since the end of World War two
sequestration kicked in in 2011 look at
what happens March since 2011 look at
the conflicts were in today that did not
exist in 2011 and look what we've done
to our capabilities literally and the
Congress has done more damage to the
military than any enemy so what I like
about President Trump he thinks
sequestration is crazy he wants to go
set it aside and dramatically increase
defense spending like Ronald Reagan so
count me in he's shot a missile it aside
dropped a bomb on him when nobody else
did good he's been a better Air lied to
Israel great he's let the military fight
ISIL we don't do it one hand tied behind
her back we're actually going after
these guys
he says the Iranian deal sucks he's
right he's trying to get a better deal
in terms of Rocketman he said I'm not
gonna let you hit America with a
nuclear-tipped missile I don't want a
war but if I have to use military force
to stop you I will he's the first
president to really challenge the North
Koreans with a threat of credible
credible military force so across the
board I think he's doing a very good job
when it comes to Iran containment policy
I think we're weak there okay let's talk
about North Korea okay last month you
put the odds of a pre-emptive attack on
North Korea at 30% 70% if there was
another nuclear where are we today and
what what should we be doing well the
first decision President Trump had to
make is how do you handle North Korea
and a nuclear program so the first time
we met in the White House of about 30
days after he got elected he apologized
for giving out my phone number and I
said that was the height of my campaign
don't worry about it that's the best I
did and he said what's your new number I
said we're gonna try this again so I
gave him my new number then we went in
and had lunch and gentlement master was
there and a few other people and he said
what what do you think my challenges
will be I said North Korea in the short
term Iran in the long term mm-hmm you
got to decide and between the following
options excuse me
Rubio moment here Marcos great on these
issues by the way do you let them have a
nuclear weapon to hit America a missile
tip to hit America and contain it by
saying if you ever use it I'll wipe you
off the map and that's one let's call
containment the other is denial
I'm never gonna allow you to develop the
technology to hit America with a nuclear
weapon and if you try to do it I'll use
military force to stop you
that's called denial he asked me what
would you do I said I'd do the second
one
yes but master he says I agree with
Senator Graham why anything they build
ill sell I don't know if he'll use it on
any given day but I don't want to live
our lives wondering if you might I want
to live our lives on what he can do I
don't want future generations of
Americans having to wonder on any given
day what can jump um or the next
kim-jong might do I don't have a big
nuclear arsenal and missiles included
and that they can sell to people who
would you say Simon the denial camp and
once you make the denial decision then
you got to have a credible threat of
military force and that's where we're at
so you mentioned the serious strike yeah
he finally enforced Obama's red line in
Syria right Syrians
we're told not to use chemical weapons
they did and he took out the base from
which they did it it's not a viable
option in North Korea could we for
example declare a ballistic missile
no-fly zone just to warn them that we
will not allow you to test any more
missiles and if you do we'll take it out
and if we don't and if you don't respond
we're not gonna take out your regime
it'll be limited to that but if you do
retaliate against the south then it's
game
well since you're my host and you're
pretty smart guy and that makes some
sense to me what's the goal is to stop
the technological advancements on their
missile program to the point they can
hit America with a nuclear-tipped
missile and all of our allies you do
that through diplomacy the key is China
but militarily and one way to stop their
technology is to say any more tests is a
provocative act and we're gonna shoot
that missile down how does this movie
end
China doesn't want a war in their
backyard we're not going to tolerate one
in ours if China really believes Trump
would use military force to stop the
threats coming from North Korea I think
they would change your behavior they own
the North Korean economy a war with
North Korea would be devastating as to
how you stop the threat the first bomb
dropped you got to assume the worst not
not the best you've got a kind of a
missile containment strategy that with a
military component that might work but
let's say the CI Pompeo comes in and
tells the president they're just a few
weeks away from having the breakthrough
I don't think you can surgically strike
North Korea they have a lot of
capability directed at South Korea and
Japan in the region so when I say the
military option is the last resort I
mean it because thousands of people
could get killed and this is the world
Donald Trump lives in you've got a
choice between homeland security
stopping a threat emanating from North
Korea to protect the homeland and the
way you protect the homeland has put
millions of people at risk that is a
very bad spot to find yourself and
everybody before Donald Trump put him
here every Republican in every
Democratic president every Congress
talked tough and did nothing so one of
the reasons I want to help the president
is he has a really hard job
right now there is no place to kick the
can when it comes to North Korea we're
getting closer to the moment that
technology connects
we be employed deployed to hit America I
am a hundred percent confident that if
he had to as a last resort he would go
to war with Kim jung-ho it would be
devastating but Kim jong-un would lose
do you think Kim jong-un believes that
because the North Koreans are behaving
one of the problems we have with trying
to get a diplomatic solution to it is
that the they are convinced that they're
in touchable because of what they can do
to Seoul right so so do they believe
that Donald Trump really is a pible and
are his tweets for example helping in
try and convince them that he's serious
and he's different from other presidents
I don't think they can hurt I think his
policies have to be real in the eyes of
your enemies so as we build up military
capability of more such makes it more
real to North Korea we're not seeking
regime change we're not trying to bring
democracy to North Korea we're not
trying to unify the peninsula we're
trying to stop a threat to our homeland
in the negging from North Korea
it's a reasonable goal clearly they
don't believe that he will use for so
they would have stopped their technology
there they're testing and the dev team
30% in 70% is if they ever explode
another warhead that's the key
miniaturizing the warhead and to put on
a missile they can survive reentry when
they go down testing the warhead more
and that means they're really getting
close so I think if there's a warhead
tested any time soon then the likelihood
of a preemptive strike likelihood of
print that strike goes up the Olympics
I like the Olympics as well as anybody
else pretty clear Hitler used the
Olympics to advance his cause he gave he
had the largest stage on the world and
they exploited it here's a simple rule
if you had the largest system of
concentration camps in the world if you
systematically rape and torture your own
people and you threaten the world with
nuclear attack you probably shouldn't go
to the Olympics I think what Kim
jong-un's going to
see out of this is that how bad could I
be I'm going to the biggest party in the
world how bad could I be if we can
negotiate an end to this I'd be the
happiest guy in the world South Korea is
a great Ally they're in a bad spot and
but I think the signals that they're
sending to North Korea are undercutting
what Trump's trying to do and which will
make it more likely that we will build
up military capability not less okay why
can't we contain them like we can't in a
Soviet Union what's the difference
ah they'll sell the technology cash
starved and crazier too bad combinations
name one weapon he's developed that he
hasn't used I mean that he hasn't sold
it's just not smart to let someone this
crazy to have a nuclear arsenal with a
capability to reach America
I don't live that way and whether he
uses it or not he's certainly likely to
sell it to somebody who will all right
the dish between North Korea and Iran I
told the president is pretty stunning
North Korea's about regime survivability
it's about a cult of a personality you
know the North Korean family lineage is
pretty interesting their grandfather
claimed to beat the Japanese all by
himself
pretty impressive Kim Jong Un's and to
be born in a volcano which is even more
impressive kim jeong-hoon
ill the grandfather this guy's father
you know said he had nine holes one in
golf the first time he played
I'll buy the volcano thing I'm not
buying that so he blows his uncle up
with anti-aircraft gun and kills his own
half-brother so I just don't like the
scenario of him having a lot of
capability Orion it's a religious regime
the people in Iran are educated very
sophisticated the Ayatollah
I think is driven by his religious
beliefs to act against those he
disagrees with if you're Israel how much
longer do you let this nuclear deal go
what the Ayatollah used a nuclear weapon
if he had it how many people believe he
would use it for religious reasons how
many people are unsure how many people
think you wouldn't if you're Israel you
better be right so we've got really
smart people here or equally divided
from he would not sure I don't think you
will you're in Israel here's a key when
you're right inside the missile death
Israel bad so on the day we voted to let
their agreement go forward by not
getting enough votes to kill it
the Ayatollah tweeted out Allah willing
and 25 years the Zionist state won't
exist they're provocative behavior in
the region proves to me that they never
wanted the money for peaceful purposes
they're trying to create instability in
the region and help Shia minorities
they're trying to spread their view of
Islam they're building up their military
with the money not roads and bridges
nobody believed Hitler when he wrote a
book hey I'd like to kill all the Jews
he'd said that directly why would we
take a risk that great for our friends
in the region and what do you think the
Arabs will do if they see him marching
toward a nuclear weapon one last
question
how many of you believe that the regime
in Iran's goal is to build a nuclear
weapon not a power plant okay if you
believe that are liars and they've been
cheating why would you keep that
capability intact even though you're
monitoring it and you're degrading it
but in 15 years they can enrich and
reprocess without limitation every Arab
state who's feels threatened by Ron is
going to make a vet
that if the world had changed the
trajectory they're gonna go nuclear and
Orion we got to get ahead of them here's
something most people don't think about
Israel is thought to have nuclear
weapons they won't confirm it but
everybody believes it name one Arab
state that got a nuclear weapon in
response to Israel nobody in the Arab
world believes that Israel's going to
wake up one day and blow them off the
map when you talk to any Arab leader
they're apoplectic about the idea of the
Ayatollah having the nuke because they
believe he will use it
welcome to Donald Trump's world how do
you get a better deal so beyond the the
question of the nuclear deal it seems
like the administration is having
trouble really
operationalizing their strategy right in
front irani and aggression around the
world and right then can you how would
you do it well one I like the
president's idea of waiving sanctions
one more time but challenging the
Congress to change
unruhe whatever the acronym for the law
is to say we're not going to honor the
sunset clause under this deal after 15
years they can enrich and reprocess
without limitation under this deal they
can take all the money from sanctions
relief and spend it any way they like no
matter how provocative their behavior is
and in this deal if we tried to sanction
them for destabilizing Yemen then the
nuclear deal is off
in the last week of this deal the
Europeans and the United States gave the
farm away so I would press Congress to
change our domestic law if they continue
to develop missiles weary impose
sanctions if they continue to be the
largest state sponsor of terrorism we
impose sanctions the Europeans don't
like it well that's just sorry in Iraq
if we don't leave a residual force
behind we're gonna lose all leverage we
have Baghdad is falling apart to all
those who fought in Iraq you did your
job the search did work we made plenty
of mistakes on Bush's watch but one
thing President Bush did was he wanted
to get it right the surge did work
political compromise
was beginning to move forward security
was vastly improved when we pulled all
of our troops out everything that
Senator McCain and I said happened and
now President Trump if he wants to make
sure ISIL doesn't come back or al-qaida
in Iraq he's got to be willing to leave
at least 10,000 troops by and to
maintain our gains and that would
actually give us some leverage in terms
of Baghdad politics very few Iraqis want
the Iranians militarily involved in Iraq
there are a lot of Iraqis believe that
we're stabilizing force so that's one
way to get leverage back I'd help
rebuild and Barre province has been
devastated but I don't want the Iraqi
government to do some political reforms
to make it worth our efforts some metric
based aid I'd leave troops there to
protect our gains that protects us as
well as the Iraqis Syria I'd break the
Russians away from the Iranians we have
no Sunni component in Syria we're
relying on Kurds that are hated by the
Turks YPG Kurds have a communist view of
the world they're never going to hold a
rock or any of the Sunni Arab territory
they're willing fighters but they could
care less about Assad Obama's biggest
mistake was basically as Hezbollah came
to Assad's aid as a Ron King two sides
aid we pulled back our support for the
Sunni Arabs that training program we had
said you couldn't fight Assad you could
only fight ISIL like ten people showed
up so now we don't have a Sunni partner
inside of Syria and we're making al
Qaeda's chance of recruiting even as you
destroy ISIL go through the roof goes to
only effective fighting force against
Assad in the Ayatollah happens to be
radical Islamic Sunnis and that's gonna
make that the gains are gonna slowly
leave and the confrontation between the
Arabs the Kurds and the Turks is just
around the corner is our focus I mean
it's great that we've driven ISIL from
its caliphate from the physical
Caliphate but have we been too focused
on ISIL in Syria as opposed to al Qaeda
which has sort of been hanging back
watching us destroy their enemy
pairing to come in and take over the
jihad and also by the way for all the
reasons you said we've been drugged
because we've been effectively
partnering with Russia and Iran they're
mortal and immortal enemies of the
Sunnis
we've been driving Sunni Arabs into the
arms of al Qaeda as is al Qaeda going to
emerge from this from this victory in
Syria as they strengthened more potent
force against us
well Sunni extremism is the biggest
winner of a policy that leaves the side
in power the average Syrian is not
buying into Assad staying in power
because he's done more to kill their
family than ISIL so this idea somehow
that we can have a settlement inside of
Syria that leaves Assad in power is
crazy
and if we have a Iranian proxy that's no
better so the war never ends as long as
Iran dominates Damascus the best way to
end this war is have the Syrian people
reconstruct themselves that we have a
credible military opposition to Assad
that you go to Geneva and try to
negotiate a settlement the Russians want
a military presence and influence I'm
willing to allow that to happen because
it was there before what I'm not willing
to do is give yet another cap Arab
capital to the Iranians and the only way
you can stop that mark is to make sure
that those who resist Assad have better
capacity than they do today
let the Russians know that you'll never
achieve the goal of putting the Iranians
in power and Damascus if that's your
endgame then you're not a reliable
partner let's talk about the terrorist
threat here at home you've been very
critical about how the Trump
administration has effectively continued
the Obama policy of law enforcement
approach to detention interrogation we
just had two terrorists who were
captured one in New York one in Libya
both were in both cases the Trump
administration followed the Obama
policies at a letter read him the
Miranda rights put him in article 3
courts why is that a bad idea and how
are we how are you going to fix it well
that's a very fair question it wasn't
shaded at all so you and I have been
living through this for life you know
this is hard stuff and so it's as if
Obama never left is a pretty hardcore
sysm all the things I said about the
president being different than President
Obama I applaud President Trump for
unleashing the military of wanting to
rebuild it being tougher on our enemies
it's done a great job standing up to
running North Korea when it comes to
detention policy and interrogation
policy it's a staff problem
I don't think Donald Trump really likes
hey mr. tariffs would you like the right
to mean silent all I'm suggesting is
that we have a wartime regime for a war
versus a criminal justice system
criminal justice is about finding out
who committed a crime making sure
they're fairly treated the law of war is
about protecting the country from an
enemy bent on our destruction
and applying our values not theirs so I
was really hard on Obama for
criminalizing the war we don't put
anyone into tension anymore every time
you kill a terrorist you're losing
intelligence gathering
I don't mind killing terrorists I'd like
to capture some of these guys alive and
figure out what they're up to
I've been a military lawyer for 33 years
the idea of reading an enemy combatant
their Miranda rights is foreign to most
military commanders and lawyers who is
an enemy combatant anybody that joins
their cause there is no recruiting an
induction Center for ISIL or Al Qaeda
you don't like go somewhere and get a
certificate here's a here's a tip what
would make an enemy combatant if you
wanted the ISIL flag in your hospital
room you're a good candidate if you got
like a a letter to ISIL in the car that
you used to kill a bunch of people
you're a good candidate now the way the
system works is the government can
declare somebody an enemy combatant
initially hold them for a period of time
then courts review whether or not that
decision is legally sound that's not are
you innocent or guilty of a crime that's
whether or not you have become an enemy
combatant through your actions
what I want to do in the future is every
time we capture somebody at home or
abroad that we believe is doing in the
name of ISIL or Al Qaeda that are part
of the terrorist network known or
unknown that we gather as much
intelligence as we can before we put
them into the criminal justice system
that's all I'm asking we treat them
humanely and we've had two instances in
the United States where it's clear to me
that Trump administration had thought
had not thought much about it the guy
that that killed eight or nine people in
New York I don't know if he has
intelligence value but I know this
you'll never find out completely by
reading his Miranda rights in their
first few hours interrogation by plea
bargaining is not the way the world
works in any war I've never heard
anybody tell me the best way to get good
information from me and your prisoners
give them a lawyer so the second guy he
didn't kill anybody thank God and why
did he go to Bangladesh can you really
be certain you know all there is to know
about this guy in a few hours in a few
days so what I would do is have
professionals come in to have a
interrogation team that Bush created
Obama Chris I'm sorry yeah
and in reactivated every time there's a
suspected terrorist attack send in
people from the intelligence community
local and international and try to
figure out who this guy has how did they
get so radicalized and do they know more
about other people who might becoming
radicalized before you put them in the
criminal justice system and you can't
talk to them without a lawyer I've been
a criminal lawyer I'm not gonna let you
ask my client a bunch of hard questions
unless I get something for it we're
trying to win a war here folks I want to
know everything there is to know about
how this terrorist attack happened what
do they know about future terrorist
attack possibilities and you can only do
that under the law
shouldn't we all be proactively
targeting people for capture as opposed
to people falling into our hands but
here's the good news
we're on defense we're all over the
world now going after terrorists you got
two choices when it comes to terrorists
lay back and wait to get hit or hit them
for they hit you that's just the way it
is so we need to stay on the offense all
over the world the likelihood of
capturing somebody today is greater than
it was on Obama's watch because we're
actually going out trying to find him
what do we do when we capture him are we
gonna use Gitmo you know I get moved
find someplace else get most fine with
me I wanted to I was willing to close it
if you had moved the prisoners to a
secure facility and treat them as enemy
combatants not common criminals the
location doesn't matter that much to me
we had like 500,000 enemy prisoners
inside the United States in World War
two what matters to me is that we hold
them consistent with a legal theory that
they're part of the enemy force there is
judicial review and there you don't have
to let people go in a war you can hold
them as long as they're dangerous under
domestic criminal law you can't hold
somebody forever without trial nor
should you be allowed to so where do we
put them and it's the CIA gonna be
allowed to question people anymore I've
always opposed torture because it's not
who we are and it helps the enemy don't
get good intelligence sir McCain spoke
only about it but I don't think the Army
Field Manual should be the exclusive
interrogation means for a nation its own
line it was written for a sergeant to
make sure that don't get themselves in a
war of law violation it should not be
the exclusive interrogation technique
there are techniques that can get good
information that are compliant with the
Geneva Convention and Convention on
torture and the CIA is out of the game
they need to be back in the game they're
experts to this I'm not talking about
waterboarding I'm talking about torture
but I think we've limited our abilities
to gather intelligence but not having an
attention sight that we can use not
having an interrogation program that
would be effective so since since the
Obama administration stopped the CIA
interrogation program and stopped
captured people we've been relying on
signals intelligence but increasingly
right and the NSA has been hobbled by a
lot of leaks Snowden and others and then
Mike Hayden recently pointed out
something which I thought was really
interesting that he said that because
we're entering an age of end-to-end
encryption we're no longer gonna be
there's a time coming up where we're no
longer going to be able to get content
we're gonna be following digital exhaust
digital exhaust is useful but we need
content to keep the country safe so
doesn't that argue that it's really
important to restart an interrogation
program of some kind because if we can't
get the content through listening then
how are we going to get it well yes it
does and and so what I'm trying to end
administration is responding pretty
positively here what are the rules of
the road for the CIA the FBI in the
military should we be looking for
terrorists how many of you want to go
look for terrorists raise your hands if
you find them don't you want to explore
it intelligence I do so the bottom line
is that we don't have a system to detain
somebody that the people in the field
believe they can use we're denying our
own ability to gather intelligence in a
rational way so it does limit you to
gathering intelligence through signal
means which the enemy is pretty good at
defeating so why would we in an age of
rising tension and threat cut our
military to historic lows take off the
table detention and interrogation of
enemies who are trying to undercut the
United States and her way of life this
is insane so president Trump is going to
rebuild the military into my Republican
friends we need to deal with the Daka
kids because it's not unreasonable to do
two things at once if that's the price
to get more military spending I gladly
will pay it to the president you've said
a lot of good things about defeating our
enemies you've been a much better
partner to our allies and even let the
military do their job
focus on repairing the damage done over
the last eight years when it comes to
attention interrogation
don't put the warfighter in the worst
possible spot catch and release
I spent a lot of time in Iraq and
Afghanistan as a jack if you want to
demoralize the troops have a system
where they catch the guy that killed
their buddy and two weeks later they're
out sometimes you have to rely on the
host country who's an unreliable partner
this is not a rot problem this is not an
Afghan problem it would be a shame to me
to have a catch and release program or
the only option is to kill the guy so
the last question then we'll turn to the
audience for some for some questions so
in the 1988 presidential debates no one
mentioned Iraq and yet a few years later
we were at war in Iraq to repeal
Saddam's invasion of Kuwait in the 2000
presidential debates and no one
mentioned al-qaeda and we were then be
in a war and a great new war on terror
and had 9/11 happen what what is the
issue that nobody's talking about today
that worries you the most I don't think
there's any issue that we're not talking
about but the issue that worries me the
most is a terrorist organization
obtaining a weapon of mass destruction
and certainly will use it so when you
look at the way the world is moving
unstable and dangerous regimes are being
allowed to have more capability not less
we're reducing our capability to gather
intelligence and find out what's going
on as we break up terrorist armies they
become terrorist organizations as on
governed spaces in Africa growth I don't
think we're doing enough to make sure
that the regimes that have weapons of
mass destruction are won't weapons of
mass destruction are being denied future
capability and the ability to pass it on
to people who use
cyberattacks are real terrorists could
do that tomorrow but they could get
ahold of a chemical or biological agent
to kill me and so us they would they get
a hold of a nuclear weapon they'd use it
the only reason they used airplanes is
because that was the best vehicle for
them to use the only reason 3,000 died
on 9/11 s not three million and not
three millions they couldn't get the
capability to kill through me and people
that capability exist over time in North
Korea and eventually in Iran I don't
think we're doing enough to stop that
problem bring that full circle you've
talked about the important to how Kim
jong-un's was gonna sell this to anybody
he was selling it he was building a
nuclear plant in Syria and it's and the
Israelis took it out if they haven't
taken that out that might be an Isis
hands today yeah that's true and if we
don't deal with Iran effectively he's
gonna think we don't mean regarding him
and if we don't enforce the denial
policy in North Korea the Iranians are
gonna say they're all talk our European
allies don't want confrontation they're
not going to do anything unless we push
them so when it comes to North Korea
they're looking at what Iran we're doing
with Iran when it comes to Iran they're
looking what we do to North Korea and
this is why I played off president Trump
has really got a lot of hard decisions
to make I think he's got a good
framework to deal from I think he sees
the threats and he's got great advisors
around him but he has a weak allies very
embolden opponents and a Congress is
beyond fractured on foreign policy all
right let's take some questions from the
audience this gentleman right here
thank you for your service hi my name is
Fred von icken from the daily Ripple
I'm also a gold star dad I had three
other children as well served in the
military
god bless and one of them one of the
other three was hit with a hand grenade
and went back into the second tour in
Afghanistan and I became a fan of yours
in 2015 when I stood on the corner of
stage at Netroots nation and used to
keep your speech and you you spoke about
your childhood and and your life as a
kid so I'm expecting an honest answer
from you and I think my family would
deserve it if if you were out playing
golf with the president and you leaned
over and said sir could you tell me the
name of the leader of Isis al-qaeda the
Taliban Boko Haram or the leader of the
group that killed those for special
service soldiers do you think he could
actually do that you know I don't know
if I could give you the answer to all of
them too but here's why I would tell
your family he knows her bad and he
wants people in your family who are
fighting to have more capability to go
after him so I don't think it really
matters if he can tell you the name of
terrorist leaders who are dying pretty
frequently I think what it matters is
he's letting your son and others fight
more effectively questions yes
thank you for coming senator my name is
Mitchell nakiya Japan native US citizen
regarding North Korea number one it's
been said that they have covert
operations to catch Kim jong-un I'm
talking about South Korea if you know
anything about it can you tell you every
detail right now nothing else if I were
you I'd keep moving around number two
president Trump said you have to do
what's best for your country because I'm
gonna do what's best for my country does
it mean this is a hypothetical question
does it mean it's okay for Japan or
South Korea to go nuclear I don't think
there was a good cause just asking the
question yeah well you know you asked a
question about you know in-depth
knowledge of people is that does they
get the big stuff right I don't think
having Japan and South Korea becoming
nuclear protects us I think it is a
containment strategy saying okay you
can't attack us because we'll wipe you
off the map and if Chuck in Japan has a
nuclear weapon well if you hit us we'll
hit you and South Korea can say well if
you hit us we'll hit you
mutual assured destruction is not what
it used to be
well the wrong way like welcomed that so
I think a mutual assured destruction is
the wrong paradigm to look at Kim jungim
through
I think denial is because I don't think
Japan and South Korea would sell a
nuclear weapon if they had one but I'm
really certain that biological nuclear
weapons in the hands of Kim Jeong them
over time bad for everybody and what do
you do if you're president if you say
deny oh you better mean it because if
you don't the Iranians are gonna go
nuclear every terrorist group in the
world is gonna say we're all talk he's
no different than Obama and I'm telling
South Korea and Japan
I don't your great allies we have
soldiers there we'll fight with you
but don't make this president have to
choose between a preemptive strike and
regional security don't make him do that
telling China that questions Jessica
thank you my name is Jessica trisko
Darden I'm a Jean Kirkpatrick fellow
here at the American Enterprise
Institute and I work on issues related
to US foreign assistance so my question
to you is someone who cares very deeply
about this issue and about American
leadership in the world is what leaders
like yourself or the Congress can do to
shore up American moral leadership and
values you mentioned the strike on Syria
many would argue that that was one act
in a long decline of u.s. moral
leadership in the world so what role do
you see for yourself in that well I
don't think it's immoral to try to to
strike aside I don't think it's immoral
to go out and put bad guys on their back
foot I think it's the right thing to do
to go after evil what's a moralistic is
to appease evil if there's one thing I
can tell you that has worked throughout
history and is that when you let evil
run rampant it will and it takes good
people to stop it like this guy's son we
never met your son I don't know where
he's from but he's having to go fight a
bunch of complicated people we've never
met simply because we believe in the
right of self-determination for us and
others we believe in certain values that
are terrorists don't we believe the
young lady should have a chance to grow
up and seek her future so this is a real
big contest between values and we're on
the right side I am on the side of
stopping radical Islam because I think
it is a scourge to mankind not Islam
radical Islam but I'm also on the side
of helping people as a form of stopping
evil
you can drop bombs in Syria and it did
some good but the biggest threat to
radical Islam is to build a small
schoolhouse for a poor young girl where
she can get an education and raise her
children and be independent enough to
express herself that drives terrorists
crazy economic opportunity will do more
damage to terrorists than military
action empowering women is the ultimate
way to win this war and foreign
assistance is one tool in the toolbox
general mattis said if you cut the State
Department's budget then you need to buy
me more bullets problem I got with this
administration how do you cut the State
Department's budget twenty-nine percent
and build up the military expect to get
a good outcome how do you hold and build
you hold and bill by having security but
you do stay on the ground like we did in
World War two and and you help people
build capacity it's hard it's
frustrating but there's no substitute
for it so the soft power component is
essential to winning the war is any
military engagement we're trying to kill
an ideology well how do you kill an
ideology you replace it here's the good
news after 42 trips to Afghanistan in
Iraq most people are not buying what
these nutjobs are selling most young
people over there don't want to join
ISIL most parents don't want their
daughter to be given to ISIL or Al Qaeda
we just need to help them when you lump
up all into one group you're doing a
great disservice to all those who are
fighting and dying there have been more
Muslims killed than anybody fighting
radical Islam I have lost eight a
significant number of people I have
known during my engagements as Colonel
Graham and Senator Graham have been
killed standing up to al Qaeda and ISIL
they need our help more than military
they need economic developmental aid if
you're serious about protecting America
you better keep the fight over there
and the best way to keep the fight over
there is to keep our our men and women
in the Intel community and soldiers
active in the enemy's backyard but you
also need to plow the ground over there
in so new seeds so without soft power
we're doomed to lose and this cutting
the State Department's budget was really
crazy and I'm in charge of that budget
and we restored the 2017 funding and
we're going to restore the 2018 funding
right there two more questions I gotta
go yep
Thank You senator Graham my name is
Jenny Park with the USA General Korea
recently our president Chomper mentioned
about open the topped with the North
Korea but not without preconditions the
North could have to give up their
nuclear programs before committing to
talks and second patience South Korea
invited the North Koreans to come
Olympics Winter Olympics and such as you
know that the North Korea is a terrorist
country but the South Korean government
will pay for all various expenses to
North Korea but South is that that the
South Korea is in violation of North
Koreans UN sanctions or US sanctions
thank you very much well I'm not gonna
say by allowing the North Koreans
participate in Olympics that we violated
the sanctions I am saying that is a very
bad message to send to Kim jong-un who
will see it in a bad way not a good way
he'll see it as weakness the North
Korean athletes I mean I have nothing
against North Korean people the average
North Koreans like three inches shorter
than average South Korea too because
just they're been starved to death I
can't believe we're wondering what to do
in 2018
about a man who
just enslaves his people and all I can
say is I don't mind talking to me I it's
fine to talk without preconditions
here's the talk I don't care if Trump
talks to it hey guy you need to knock us
off if you keep this up we're going to
make sure that you never have the
ability to hit our homeland we're not
trying to change your regime we're not
bringing democracy but if you keep this
up there's going to be a war and you're
gonna lose it thank you very much I want
him to understand what comes his way if
he keeps building the capabilities he's
hell-bent on developing and I want Trump
to prove to China South Korea of Japan
North Korea that he means it
I think he means it and the one thing
about the Olympics is I think it will be
taken is that we really don't mean it
how do you tell somebody in one breath a
little Rocket Man you're evil bad
whatever invite him to the biggest party
on the planet all right last question
hi Thank You Rachael Oswald
congressional quarterly another question
on North Korea um senator some of the
things you said if you could provide a
little bit more clarity on you said that
Trump sees an attack on North Korea as a
last resort but military strike how
would you define that is that if we see
them on the verge of getting a
deliberate deliverable ICBM or that they
have something on the launch pad that
would be striking can you say talk a
little talk a little bit about
preventative versus preemptive and Trump
sighs okay military options last resort
means that diplomacy has to be used as
full extent I don't mind talking I
wouldn't even put any conditions on
talking because I want to deliver the
right message let's try to engage China
to the fullest extent possible use
Garrett's used sticks whatever we need
to do so that first meeting was
somebody's going to come in this office
one day and say they're close we think
they're there it's just a matter of time
so I know there's some red lines and in
the president's mind I know there are
some red lines that our Intel community
believes exists certainly not going to
share them publicly but this is not an
ill-conceived idea about the dial
when does that moment come it's when
their program matures and goes across
these red lines at the pace we're on and
it's just a matter of time if something
doesn't change it will be inevitable
that these red lines are met if there's
another test of a warhead now why did I
say that it dramatically accelerates
likely to preemptive action because
that's sort of one of the missing pieces
of the puzzle and here's the problem in
a totalitarian regime it is hard to
gather good intelligence you know you
can be wrong we've seen that in the past
right but you got to make a you got to
make a decision
where are they headed and what do they
want to do all the indications to me
that they're headed to the achieving the
capability that President Trump says he
would deny because they're
miscalculating they're believing they
get that capability of their home free
that everybody will leave them alone in
perpetuity and only without a nuclear
weapon that can hit America are they
safe and there's some evidence out there
that if you give up your weapons of mass
destruction it's probably not a good
thing look at the Ukraine the Ukraine
had it to do all over again what they've
done that I don't want proliferation of
nuclear weapons into the hands of people
who might use them regimes who might
sell them to the people who might use
them is my biggest concern so in terms
of time I don't know exactly but it's
general McMaster said we're running out
of time ladies and gentleman if you
could stay in your seats while senator
Graham departs the room thank you so
much for being here thank you
[Applause]